تتسرعوا التطورات في جبهه خرسون حيث قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان دفاعاته الجويه اسقطت
مروحيتين روسيتين ودمرت ثلاثه مستودعات
ذخيره تطورات دفعت سلطات المواليه لروسيا
الى اجلاء نحو 700 من سكان مدينه كخوفكا
على نهر النيبرو باتجاه المناطق الروسيه
عسكريا بكامله حاولت القوه الروسيه نقله
من خرسون عبر نهر النيبرو الى جانب مركب
شحن روسي قرب
ذكرت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه اسقطت صاروخي
القوه الاوكرانيه على المدينه
وقالت مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان اشدها تلك
التي دارت على محور مدينه باخمود في
المقابل افادت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
بحدوث انفجارات ضخمه بصوداعتي للاسلحه
والذخائر التابعه للجيش الاوكراني في
مدينه بكروفيسك غربي دونيتسك